معنا من السوق المركزي في الخرطوم بحري
مراسله الجزيره محمد الطيب محمد اذا هنالك
قصف طال ايضا الخرطوم بحري ما الذي يجري
نعم
هناك قصف للطيران في نسمعه تحليق الطيران
والمضادات الطائرات من قوه الدعم السريع
التي تحاول ابعادها من هذه المناطق عموما
اليوم شهد عمليه
حركه للطيران كانت كثيفه منذ وقت الصباح
وحتى هذه اللحظه والان نسمع اصوات الطياره
نحن الان في
سوق بحري في محطه الوسطى هذا سوق احترق
بالكامل خلال
قبل اسبوع
وهذه هي اثاره ما زالت مضادات الطيران
تضرب مناطق مختلفه هذه قذيفه ربما نسمعها
الان تنفجر في هذه المنطقه
نحاول ان نبتعد قليلا من
المناطق التي يبدو ان فيها جزء من
الاشتباكات او جزء من المواجهات طبيعتك
قتال هنا هنا الطبيعه تعتمد على سلاح الجو
وعلى المدفعيه التي يحول الجيش
قد نشرت فيديوهات لقواتها في قبل ايام
اليس كذلك
في الواقع نحن في منطقه
محطه الوسطى في سوق البحري
لم نطلع على هذه الفيديوهات التي نشرتها
قوات الدعم السريع لكن قوات الدعم السريع
دائما ما توجه الاتهام بانه يستهدف مناطق
سكنيه ومناطقها وبالتالي رد الجيش
ببياناته بانه يستهدف مقرات تابعه للدعم
السريع وهو يحاول اعاقتها بحسب بياناته من
اي خطوط امداد او اي شكل من اشكال
الانتشار نحن الان هنا في هذا السوق هذا
السوق الان كما ترونه هو محروق بالكامل
ليست فيه اثر فيه حركه عمليه الحرق التي
تمت فيه في الواقع هي مجهوله المصدر ما هو
سبب حريقه هو من اهم الاسواق الان في سوق
بحري هذه المنطقه يبدو انها منطقه ساخنه
نسمع فيها مضادات الطائرات من قوات الدعم
السريع
ونسمع فيها تحليق الطيران الذي لا ادري ان
كنتم تسمعونه ام لا لكن الطيران في هذه
المنطقه النشط جدا ومنذ
الصباح في مناطق مختلفه سجلنا ان هناك تمت
عمليه قصف لمناطق اخرى تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع قال الجيش انه استهدفا من خلال
الطيران
لكن هذه المنطقه ما تزال
طبيعه الاشتباكات فيها مبنيه على القذف
مبنيه على
المقذوفات على القصف ومبنيه على المدافع
ومضادات الطائرات
ليست هنا في هذه المنطقه بالتحديد هنا في
المحطه الوسطى في بحري اي شك من اشكال
المواجهات المباشره ما بين قوات الدعم
السريع وما بين الجيش الجيش يبدو انه يتخذ
استراتيجيه
محاوله الا ضعاف اضافه الامداد بعمليات
قصفه لمناطق التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع
او اي عمليه من عمليات الامداد او
تجمعاتهم فبالتالي هذه السياسه التي يبدو
ان الجيش يتبعها خلال الفتره الماضيه هنا
في هذا السوق
المنطقه البحري عموما اصبحت ليست
كسابقاتها الشلل شلل في الحركه شلل في
الشوارع الرئيسيه الحركه فيها متوقفه
اغلبيه المحاله التجاريه
مقفله هناك انقطاع في عدد من الاحيان قطاع
الماء والكهرباء اثر في حياه الناس مما
جعلهم ينزحون الى مناطق اخرى هذا احد اهم
الاسواق في بحري الان هو محترق بالكامل
ليست فيه حركه ونسمع الان الطائره
سلاح الجو يحلق في هذه المنطقه تقوم قوات
الدعم السريع
بمحاوله ابعادها باطلاق مضادات الطائرات
التي سمعتموها
خلال هذا اليوم على ان اليوم كان
يعتبره مواطنون انه اقل كثافه من حيث
العمليات الجويه والمضادات لكن يبدو ان
الوضع الان تغير نوعا ما اصبحت ماذا عن
الناس محمد
ارى حركه خفيفه يمكن شخص صانع او ثلاثه
خلفك فقط لكن هل هنالك اي سكان في هذه
المنطقه المراحلوا جميعا المناطق الاخرى
التي رحل عنها سكانها
بالكاد بالكاد ليست هناك
متاجر تفتح ابوابها للناس في هذه المنطقه
وليست هناك
طرمبات للبنزين الحركه هنا ضعيفه كل من
اراد ان يحاول ان ياتي بجزء من امتعته
ياتي هنا وياخذها ثم بعد ذلك يخطب بعيدا
هذه المناطق نوعا ما بسبب السماع هذا
الصوت
الذي ربما سبب ازعاجا لمواطنين الذين
يسكنون هذه المناطق
وانقطاع الكهرباء
والماء جعلت كثير من سكان يخرجون وينادي
المنطقه كليا ويذهبون الى مناطق اكثر
امانا ما زال يحلق هذه المنطقه
القوات الدعم السريعه تقوم بمحاولات
ابعاده عبر مضادات الطائرات التي تحاول ان
تطلقها لابعاده عن هذه المنطقه نوعا ما
عموما كما تلاحظون حول ان نبتعد من
المنطقه تكون غير امنه
ناتي الى هذا الشارع على العموم هذا السوق
كما ترون الان سوق فارغ هذا امتداد السوق
محمد تلك الناحيه ليس هناك شيء يذكر ان
كنت تسمعني يا زين هذا السوق الان خاويه
على عروشه ليس فيه الشخص ليست فيه متاجر
مفتوحه وتعرضت اكثر منه للنهب والسلب شكرا
لك محمد الطيب من السوق المركزي في
الخرطوم بحري طبعا بعد قصفه وشكرا لهذه
اللقطات وان شاء الله تتحرك الى مكان اكثر
امنا